The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Hello, welcome.
As you expect, the big news is
that there's a quiz next week.
So hopefully, that's all square,
everybody knows everything.
Questions, comments?
Everybody's pretty
comfortable with what's
going on with the quiz?
If you have a conflict,
please contact me shortly,
because I have to arrange
rooms and proctors.
No questions?
Good.
So last time we looked at
discrete time frequency
responses.
Lots of things were similar.
A few things were different.
The first difference we saw
was that in discrete time,
we like to think about complex
geometric sequences rather than
complex exponential sequences.
And the effect of that is
that the frequency response
lives on the unit circle.
So if you try to think about
a discrete time system,
say, characterized
by a z-transform
and think about what would
be its output when there
is a sinusoidal
input, just like CT,
if you have a sinusoidal
input, there's
going to be a sinusoidal
output at the same frequency.
But the amplitude and
phase can be shifted.
But to compute the amplitude
and the phase for a DT system,
you look at the unit
circle of the z-transform.
That's as distinct from the
Laplace transform in CT,
we looked at the j omega-axis.
So now, everything we used to
say about the j omega-axis,
we say about the unit circle.
Other than that, things
are extremely similar.
And just to boost
your confidence
so you know exactly what's
going on, here's a question.
What if I gave you
a system that had
a single pole and a single zero,
and say the pole and zero are
related that way?
How would you think
about that system--
Low pass, high pass, all
pass, band pass, band stop,
high stop, low stop, all stop?
AUDIENCE: I say low pass.
AUDIENCE: Low pass.
AUDIENCE: Band pass.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
some very early votes
that are completely correct.
You had the recitation, so
then there is no excuse.
So if I see any wrong answers--
and I see wrong answers.
[LAUGHTER]
Ah!
So maybe I should have the
recitation instructor-- well,
no, no, OK, everybody votes.
So high pass, low pass, band
pass, all pass, band stop,
none of the above, vote.
The vast majority
is 100% correct.
The vast majority is correct,
but it's not quite 100%.
So the answer is 4, all pass.
Why?
Can somebody make
an argument why
that should be all pass, other
than you saw it yesterday
in recitation?
[LAUGHTER]
I mean that's a good reason.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It can no longer go
through the axis below omega.
The magnitude of the zero
divided by the magnitude
of the pole is pretty large.
And then as you go to
infinite omega, it goes to 1.
So I think it's going to pass.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So I'm a little
bothered by infinite omega.
Where should we be--
when we think about things as
low pass, high pass, whatever,
what are we thinking
about when we say
something is a low pass filter?
So somebody says this.
So what's that mean?
That's correct.
So a large fraction
of this class
is learning to interpret
sign language in the air.
And so what's it mean
if a system is low pass?
What do I look for when
I look at this diagram
to see that
something's low pass?
AUDIENCE: Look for
lower frequencies.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Where is low
frequencies on this diagram?
AUDIENCE: If you cut in half--
DENNIS FREEMAN: Cut it in half,
top and bottom, take that side.
[LAUGHTER]
So low frequencies are there.
So we're thinking
about frequencies
being e to the j omega,
because what we're
thinking of or
thinking about, we'd
like to think about
cosine of omega n.
But we want to make that
look like an eigenfunction.
So we want to make that
look like e to the j omega n
plus e to the minus j omega
n, that kind of thing--
then divide by 1/2 probably.
So the question is--
so this is all pass.
And that's actually
kind of tricky,
if you think about how
it would become that way.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] at any
point on the unit circle--
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It stems
from the [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: That's
precisely right.
So somehow, if you took this
distance and that distance,
which is intended in this
figure not to look the same,
but if you took the ratio--
because this one is a zero,
so it's in the top, and
this one is a pole, so it's
in the bottom-- and if you took
that ratio, somehow if you took
that ratio divided by
that ratio and compared it
to this one divided by
that one, those numbers
would be the same thing.
That's what would
have to happen.
You would compute the magnitude
of the frequency response
by taking the ratio of the
magnitudes of the vectors
that connect the zero
to the point of interest
and the pole to the point
of interest-- the point
of interest being
on the unit circle.
It's not at all obvious to me
that that ratio is a constant,
if you move along a circle.
That's another one
of those things
that I think I need
Greek to convince me.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
because he figured it out.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Oh, somebody knows.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
guy [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Wonderful.
So you should explain it to me.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: He explained it to me.
DENNIS FREEMAN: [LAUGHS]
Putting you on the spot.
AUDIENCE: Like right now?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Oh, that's OK.
If you want to, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So if you have
any point on the unit circle?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You draw like a line
from that point to the origin.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So if you have
any point on the unit circle,
say that one--
AUDIENCE: So you
draw a line halfway--
could you do it on the other
side, on that side [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So you
like this side better, OK.
AUDIENCE: So you draw a line
from that point to the origin.
[INAUDIBLE] 1 over a
and a on the x-axis.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
So 1 over a and a.
AUDIENCE: And draw set of
lines from those to the point
of [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Up here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So now like you have
two triangles that
have the same side
and the same angle.
And if you just use
the law of cosines--
DENNIS FREEMAN: You have two--
AUDIENCE: So you have a big
triangle and a small triangle.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
we have this triangle
and we have this triangle.
Those are the two you want?
AUDIENCE: And yeah.
So like they have--
the line of the leftmost
is like the same for both.
And the angle at the center
is the same for both.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So this
angle is equal to this angle?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: The central angle.
The central angle with the--
AUDIENCE: You take the
whole be triangle and--
DENNIS FREEMAN: Take
the big triangle--
AUDIENCE: And the origin.
AUDIENCE: And then
the one you just--
AUDIENCE: The angle
at the origin.
DENNIS FREEMAN: And the
angle at the origin.
AUDIENCE: Yes, that one.
AUDIENCE: So that angle is
in both the big triangle
and the little one.
DENNIS FREEMAN: That angle
is in the big triangle
and the little one?
Yes!
[LAUGHTER]
Got it!
AUDIENCE: And the
size of the bottom
are like 1/a and a
for the two triangles.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you just use
the law of cosines and--
DENNIS FREEMAN:
That's very good.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that pretty?
DENNIS FREEMAN: What was that?
DENNIS FREEMAN: That's amazing.
So wonderful.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
So you're also working
on the triangle thing?
Don't have that yet.
OK.
I'll keep checking in.
So the way people who don't do
quite so well in trig do it,
so you can also just
empty-headedly substitute z
equals e to the j omega.
And then if you want to make
the top look a little bit more
like the bottom, you could take
out the e to the j omega part.
And then you see that these
look like complex conjugates.
So this is kind of the math way.
And what you said
was the trig way.
I like the trig way much better,
the [INAUDIBLE] way, yes.
So complex conjugates,
same magnitude done.
So the whole point was
just to motivate the idea
of thinking about an all pass.
Why would you build an all pass?
What's an all pass good for?
It's 6.003 exercises, of course.
So an all pass doesn't
change the magnitudes.
So what's it good for?
AUDIENCE: Changes the phase.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Changes the phase.
So if you were to
think about what's
the phase of the all
pass, you get a function
that depends differently.
So you have to compute the
angles of these vectors.
So this one-- the angle at
the zero starts out at pi.
The angle associated with
the pole starts out at zero.
There's actually a minus sign in
here, because I took 1 minus z
compared to z minus a.
So I put the z at
the two places.
So there's a net minus sign in
the whole transfer function.
So the pi cancels out the pi.
So we start at zero at zero.
Everybody know what I just said?
So the angle associated
with the zero is pi.
But there's also a negative sign
associated with the transfer
function, because we would
normally like to write z
minus a 0 divided
by z minus a pole.
And I didn't write it that way.
The top one, I wrote backwards.
So there's a net minus sign.
Because of the minus
sign, the phase
starts out at zero
instead of pi.
That's how that got to be zero.
So this starts out at pi--
the angle starts out at pi.
It becomes less, and then
it goes back to being pi.
But the angle associated
with the pole starts at zero
and goes around the pi.
So the net from the
pole is a pi shift,
which accounts for why this
goes from 0 to minus pi.
You can all do that, right?
So the idea is that the all
pass would alter the phase.
And that's one of the things
I wanted to talk about.
What's the effect of
changing the phase?
And I'll do a demo now, thinking
about how it affects audio.
And at the end of
the hour, thinking
about how it affects video.
So to think about this,
I took this fraction.
And I used a equals 0.95.
And I took a waveform that
I generated with Python.
I just added together
three tones in the ratio
1, 3, 5 in frequencies, so
it sounds like more harmonic.
And when you add those together,
you get a sound like this.
[TONES PLAYING]
What you hear is a very dominant
tone-- a very dominant pitch,
because I made the harmonics
be integer multiples.
So I made the overtones
be integer multiples
of the fundamental.
So the fundamental was at 8,440.
And I put in some third harmonic
and some fifth harmonic.
So you get something that
sounds very constant pitch.
Then I took that waveform and
put it through this filter.
And that changes this
looking wave form
into that looking waveform.
Those are real waveforms.
And then it changes
the sound, so
that instead of sounding
like this [TONES PLAYING],
it sounds like [TONES PLAYING].
[LAUGHTER]
You can all hear the
enormous difference, right?
So even with headphones, I can't
hear any difference at all.
And that's kind of a
property of the way you hear.
You kind of hear--
I'll say some
caveats about this.
This is not exactly true.
So Ohm's law of hearing--
the same Ohm-- says that you
hear sounds by the frequencies
that they contain.
Roughly speaking,
you hear sounds
according to the magnitude of
the frequencies that you hear.
Now, that's not quite true,
but it's sort of true.
So let me do a more
complicated example.
So the first sound is a
consonant vowel consonant.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Bat.
[END PLAYBACK]
DENNIS FREEMAN: And then I put
it through the same all pass.
So I screw up the phases.
So it goes from looking like
this to looking like this
and sounding like--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Bat.
[END PLAYBACK]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Hard
to hear the difference.
Here's an even more
complicated sound.
This is Bob Donovan's thesis.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE] but you
see I have no brain.
[END PLAYBACK]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Put that through
the all pass, and you get--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE] for seeking
[INAUDIBLE] but you see I have
no brain.
[END PLAYBACK]
DENNIS FREEMAN: If I listen
to that on headphones,
I can actually
hear a difference.
But I study hearing, and
I know what to listen for.
It's still difficult
to tell the difference.
Now, that's because
I kind of cheated.
To let you know
how I cheated, let
me do something more
drastic to the phase.
Let me play the
waveform backwards.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Now, you could
probably hear the difference.
[LAUGHTER]
So now, check yourself.
How does the phase
of the second signal
compare to the phase
of the first signal?
So look at each other so
you can blame each other.
If you work on this in solitary,
then I'll have to blame you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So it's
a phase relationship
between the x signal
and the y signal.
If I showed you the Fourier
transform for the x signal
and looked at the y signal,
which is x of minus n,
how would the two look--
the same or different?
I sort of gave it away.
Flipping in time does what to
the magnitude of the Fourier
transform?
Flipping time--
AUDIENCE: Change the magnitude?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Doesn't
change the magnitude at all.
What does it do?
AUDIENCE: The phase.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Flips
the sign of the phase.
That's exactly right.
So if you're into math-y
these sort of things,
you can think of representing
the two as Fourier series--
the ak's and the bk's.
And if you think
about what happens
if you have x of minus n, you
can do a change of variable,
make that look like x of n.
Then it looks more like the
Fourier series equation,
except that now I
lost my minus sign.
So a sub k is the
same as b sub minus k.
The effect is to flip
the sign of the phase.
Why would that be so much more
audible than the other things
that I showed you?
Flipping the sign of a phase,
why would that be audible?
What would it mean if I flipped
the sign from 68 degrees
to minus 68 degrees?
Not a clue.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For a total time,
it wouldn't change a thing.
But for any sign terms, it
would invert that over that.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So it'd invert--
Let's see, if you went
from plus 68 to minus 68--
so say I had cosine of
omega n plus 68 degrees
and cosine omega n
minus 68 degrees.
So I change the phase by
flipping the sign of it.
How would that change
the relationship
between the two signals?
What's phase?
Intuitively, what's phase?
Yeah, it's this way.
It's a time shift.
So the problem with
this phase shift
is that you're shifting all
the different components
by different amounts of phase.
So you might have a little
bit of 68 hertz and 72 hertz
and 3 kilohertz and 512 hertz.
And all of those are
getting their phase flipped.
So whatever it came out--
13, 128, whatever--
it becomes minus that.
All of those phase shifts
represent a time shift.
All the components are
being shifted in time.
So you're shifting
around things,
all the different
components, by some amount.
And what your ear is
actually very sensitive to
is the low frequencies.
When you shift the
low frequencies
by an amount of phase,
that's a big time.
So if you think about the
fundamental frequency that
started when the
utterance began and went
to the end of the utterance,
that was like two seconds.
So whatever that
phase is, it got
inverted, which is a large
fraction of two seconds
probably.
You can easily hear a
time-shift of two seconds.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you notice it,
if it was just a pure tone?
DENNIS FREEMAN: If it
were just a pure tone,
you would have no clue.
AUDIENCE: Or you can [INAUDIBLE]
overtones very simple.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So to make
Ohm's law a little more precise,
what your ear really does is
it does band pass filters.
If the components fall
very close to each other,
you can hear the phase shift.
If the components are far
from each other, you can't.
Even the second overtone
of a fundamental
is far enough away
that you can't
hear the relative phase of it.
The frequency components have
to be very close together.
So you can hear phase only in
a very particular case when
there's frequency
components that
are very close to
each other and there's
a relatively big shift in the
phase of those two signals.
Except for that,
Ohm's law is true.
The point is just that the
Fourier series gives us
a way of thinking about a
very interesting dimension
of a signal--
one that separates things
that are audible from things
that are not audible.
So when you're doing
signal processing,
you can pay less attention to
the thing that's not audible.
You can go ahead and distort
that, and nobody will know.
But you have to
pay close attention
to the things
that's very audible,
which is the magnitude.
We'll see at the end of the
hour that that situation is
completely flipped for video.
But before we get there--
so the first thing
to think about
was the idea of
circular frequency--
the fact that we're looking
at frequency responses living
on the unit circle, rather
than on the j omega-axis.
The second big
difference with the DT
is the frequencies are cyclic.
So rather than having
harmonics go the whole way up
to infinity, as we did in CT--
In CT, we would have a
Fourier series constructed
of the fundamental, the second
harmonic, the third harmonic,
the fourth harmonic, the
fifth harmonic, the whole way
out to infinity, in
principle at least.
In DT, they rap, so that you
get a finite number of them.
In fact, if you're taking a
sequence of length N, here
illustrated for 8, you get
eight possible frequencies,
half of which are negative.
And you don't care
about those anyway.
So the number of frequency
components for a DT signal
is finite--
for DT Fourier series.
That has enormous implications.
It means that when you do a
Fourier series decomposition,
there's a finite
number of terms.
That's enormous, because that
means that, if you started out
with a sequence of
length cap N, say 1,024,
and you take the
Fourier series of it
in order to think about
the frequency content,
you can replace the
1,024 numbers in time
with 1,024 numbers in frequency.
There's no-- well,
no is exaggeration.
There is a factor of two
kind of explosion of data,
because I went from N
real-valued signals, samples,
to N complex-valued signals.
That's not quite true either,
because of the reasons
about how information works.
The-- how do I want to say it?
The resolution that you need
for the frequency domain
representation is
actually slightly smaller.
To a first order, you're
replacing [? N ?] with [? n ?]
That's really good,
because if you
think about the
alternative in CT,
you would be replacing a
signal with an infinite number.
And that's just not
reasonable, if you
want to think about
processing signals
with digital electronics.
There's no way that
you could process
an infinite number of signals
in a finite amount of time.
So the fact that you're
replacing n samples in time
with n samples in frequency
really lends itself
to doing signal processing
using digital techniques.
Now, the problem is--
and just one way of thinking
about the finite length
is that you can think
about it by matrix.
That's just a mnemonic
that helps me a lot,
to think about how, if I
have a four-length sequence,
you go through some matrix.
And what comes out is a
four-length frequency response.
You have some
eight-length sequence,
you go through some matrix.
And then comes out some
eight-length frequency
representation.
And there's actually
a lot of intuition
that you can draw in making
the parallels between matrix
representations and the
Fourier representation,
because it is a transformation,
a linear transformation,
just like the matrix implies.
There is one problem with that
finite representation idea.
And that is that
it scales poorly.
If you think about having
a two-length sequence,
the two-length sequence has
a two-length representation
in frequency via
the Fourier series.
And that representation
has how many coefficients?
Four-- two and two.
Now, if I do of four, I get
four, how many coefficients?
4 by 4 is 16.
Now, some of these are 1's.
Right So all of these are 1's.
As you make the sequence
bigger and bigger and bigger,
however, the number
of trivial entries
gets smaller and smaller
and smaller relative.
So as you go from a
two-length sequence
to a four-length sequence
to an eight-length sequence,
now we're up to 64
multiplies in order
to convert a time-domain
representation
into a frequency-domain
representation.
Well, that's bad, because the
kinds of things we want to do
are not two and four and eight.
The kinds of things
we want to do
are manipulations
on signals of 10
to the sixth, 10 to the
eighth, 10 to the 12th.
For my doctoral thesis, I did
some fluid dynamic problems,
where the calculations had
10 to the sixth unknowns.
And I used frequency
domain techniques,
which I was able to implement
with things that I'll
talk about in a minute.
If we had used this
scaling by the square,
it just wouldn't have worked.
If you have 10 to
the sixth unknowns
and if you're
using a method that
converts from one representation
to another that involves 10
to the 12th operations,
that's just not a good idea.
So that's bad.
So by the theory of lectures,
what I'm about to tell you is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: There's is
a great way to fix this.
If there weren't, I
wouldn't tell you.
I wouldn't pose the problem.
So the question is how to
think about this scaling
in order to not have the
number of calculations
that you need to do
blow up with N square.
So in order to
motivate this, I've
used a funny notation,
where the W represents
the N-th primary root of 1.
That just saves me
from writing out e
to the j 2 pi over N 64
times, which when I did it,
it didn't fit on one slide.
I had to compress it too
much, and you couldn't see it.
So just to save space,
every time I say W8,0,
all I mean is compute the eighth
root of 1 and then raise it
to the 0-th power.
Compute the eighth root
of 1 and then raise it
to the seventh power.
That's all that means.
So the idea is, is
there a way that we
can think about the structure
of this matrix more simply?
And in particular, is there a
way to use divide and conquer?
That's our best algorithm.
It would be great if we could
take the eight-point sequence
and substitute in its
place finding the frequency
representations for two
four-point sequences.
And by the theory of lecture's,
that's what I'm about to do.
So the idea is, what
if I just simply took
the even entries in this
more complicated problem--
so I have eight entries, none
of which are necessarily 0.
So I have x0 through x7.
And I want to find the frequency
representation c0 through c7.
What if I just did the evens
and the odds separately?
That'd be great.
In order to do eight
in one fell swoop,
I need 64 multiplications.
In order to do each of these
problems, I have 16 for each.
That's only 32,
I have a big win.
But now, I'm left with, is there
a way to relate these things--
these ak's and bk's
back to the original ck?
So the idea then
is, how would you
think about the
contribution of the evens,
as opposed to the odds in
the overall calculation?
So think about the even-numbered
entries in the signal,
think about the
transformation if you
were to do a frequency
representation for that
via the Fourier series, so
that you get a0 through a3.
The first thing you see
is that these numbers
have W sub 4, the fourth root.
I need W sub 8, the eighth root.
But there's a simple identity.
If I know the eighth
root, I can just
square it to get
the fourth root.
So I can rewrite
the fourth root guys
in terms of equivalent
eighth root guys.
That was trivial.
Nod your head,
completely trivial.
And then I can say, well,
OK here's my problem
that I would like to solve.
What if I was only thinking
about the contribution
of the evens?
If I'm only worried about the
contributions of the evens,
then I don't need to worry
about some of the columns,
because they don't
contribute to the evens.
That's worth thinking about
things in terms of the matrix
helps us.
We can visualize operations
as operations on a matrix.
So now, if I'm only
worried about the evens,
I only need to worry about
four of these columns.
And if I squint at this, I
can see that W8,0 0, 0 0,
that's the same row as up here.
So this is the same as that.
And this one, W8--
so those are all W8's, I
don't even to say that--
0, 2, 4, 6; 0, 2, 4, 6;
0, 4, 0, 4; 0, 4, 0, 4.
These numbers are just
the eight coefficients.
Furthermore, it repeats.
0, 0, 0, 0 is the
same as 0, 0, 0, 0.
So that's 8,0, and that's 8,0.
What I just found was that
the way the evens effect
the answer is precisely
by taking their Fourier
representation and
repeating it twice in time.
Well, that's pretty cute.
So therefore, the contribution
of the four-length sequences
to the eight-length
sequences is showed this way.
Stack up the frequency
representations for the four,
and that is their
contribution to the eight.
The same sort of thing
happens when I do the odds.
Now, if I only
look at the odds, I
throw away a different
set of four columns.
And now, if I try
to compare that
to what I have up
here for the odds,
I don't quite get
something as easy.
So if I look down this column,
they should have all been 0.
But if I look down this column,
it's 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
If I look down this column--
0, 2, 4; 0, 3, 6--
I'm not quite getting
the right answers.
But it turns out that, if I
simply factor this number out,
so that I make the
first coefficient right,
all of the other
coefficients are right too.
So I got an easy rule now for
how the Fourier coefficients
for the odds contribute
to the answer
for the eight-length sequence.
And now, all I need to do
is glue those two together.
So the way I can calculate
the eight-length sequence
is to calculate the a's and
b's from four-length sequences
and then paste them
together this way.
And I'll get the
eight-length answer.
Now, pasting them together
takes some multiplies.
So it took me 16 to
compute the a0 to a3.
It took me 16 multiplies
to figure out b0 to b3.
So I'm up to 32.
Then I have to do eight more
to make the b's look right.
So if I just count
multiplies, I'm now doing 40.
But that's a win, because
that's compared to 64.
And I get precisely
the same answer.
That algorithm--
that's an algorithm;
that's a rule-based system for
how you take one set of eight
numbers and turn it into
a different set of eight
numbers-- that algorithm
is called the FFT, the Fast
Fourier Transform.
That's mostly to confuse you,
because it's not a transform,
but it is fast.
So it's really a
fast Fourier series.
And in fact, the guys who
figured it out knew that.
And I don't know why we insist
on trying to confuse you.
That's perhaps our job.
But the FFT, fast
Fourier transform,
is really the fast
Fourier series.
And the idea is that it's
a divide and conquer thing.
So if you think
about extending it--
So I motivated it by thinking
about how to calculate the 8
by 8 from two 4 by 4's.
But let's start from
0 and say, let's
like capital M represent
however multiplies
it took to get an endpoint FFT.
How many multiplies does it
take to do a 1-point FFT?
If my signal is periodic in 1--
so what's the relationship
between the series
representation and the time
representation if the length is
capital N equals 1?
The relationship is identity.
If my sequence was 17, 17,
17, 17, 17, 17, 17, 17, 17,
17, which is a sequence
that has a period of 1,
then the series representation
is 17, 17, 17, 17-- not
all that surprising.
So it takes exactly 0 multiplies
to calculate that one.
How many multiplies does it
take to calculate a length 2?
Well, you do two
length 1 problems.
And then because
it's length 2, you
have to do those two
extra multiplies.
Then take a length 2
and turn it into a 4,
how many multiplies for 4?
Well, you have to
do two length 2,
but now it's length 4, so
there's 4 gluing multiplies.
To do 32, you have
to do two length 16.
And then there's 32 gluing.
When you're all done, it
takes eight N times log N.
And the point is
that N times log
N can be a lot smaller
than N squared.
So let's go back to the
motivational example.
The idea was, what if I had
about 10 to the sixth unknowns?
So that's about 2 to the 20th?
Yeah, that's right.
So 2 to the 10th is
10 cubed roughly.
1,024 is 1,000 in CS terms.
So I have about 2 to the 20th.
So what would be the savings
if I did the FFT rather
than the direct form N squared?
AUDIENCE: That would be 2 to
the 20th divided by [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So I need
to take 2 to 20th times 2
to the 20th would be
the N squared algorithm.
And the other algorithm
would be 2 to the 20th--
AUDIENCE: By 20.
DENNIS FREEMAN: --divided by 20.
It's enormous difference,
that's the point.
So just a little bit
of historic context.
That algorithm has been
repeatedly invented in time.
So we usually cite
Cooley and Tukey.
They wrote a classic
paper in 1965.
The title of their
paper was "An Algorithm
for the Machine Calculation
of Complex Fourier Series."
They knew it was series.
That was 1965.
That was when computers
were starting to get big.
They actually went on and solved
some very interesting problems,
including neuroscience.
They were the first people who
solved Hodgkin-Huxley's model
for a propagated
action potential
and showed that the equations
that Hodgkin and Huxley had
found for biology actually work.
So that was 1965.
However, before them in
1942, Danielson and Lanczos
had independently discovered it.
In 1903, Runge
had discovered it.
And, in 1805,
Gauss described it.
Now, there's a
good reason why all
these brilliant scientists--
so Gauss noted it
and even used it,
but he commented on
how useless it was.
Why would Gauss
think it was useless?
He was kind of smart.
AUDIENCE: Was
Fourier alive then?
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
Gauss actually died
before he published this.
But it got published
posthumously
before Fourier started to work.
So this came before Fourier.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So why did
Gauss think this was useless?
And that's 1805.
And now, we come around to
1965, and Cooley and Tukey
make this huge deal.
And they're world-famous
because of their rediscovery
of something that
Gauss knew in 1905.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
you're not going
to be doing anything that's
like 128 by 128 by hand anyway.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
That's exactly right.
So when Gauss was thinking about
it, he was thinking about 16
by 16.
And so, yeah, you
save two, big deal.
He was much more actually
impressed with logarithms,
because he was doing
the multiplies by hand.
And the log made it much
easier to do multiplies,
because you could
substitute addition.
So he actually commented on
how useful logarithms are.
And he didn't comment
on how useful this is.
But now, we make a big
deal in the other order.
And it's entirely
digital computation.
So when we solve systems
of 10 to the sixth or 10
to the 10th unknowns,
this is an enormous deal.
And logarithms are good too.
[LAUGHTER]
But this is an enormous deal.
So one more piece of theory
and then one more ending thing.
The piece of theory is
going from periodic signals
to aperiodic.
And not surprisingly, that
works just the way it did in CT.
In fact, there's
nothing new here.
We can think about how would
you make a Fourier transform
compared to a Fourier series.
With the CT, we developed
the theory for series first,
because it was easier.
And then we derived the
theory for aperiodic signals.
By something called
periodic extension,
we took an aperiodic
signal, like this CT signal,
made it periodic,
like that DT signal,
and then took the limit as
the period goes to infinity.
Had we stayed in time
domain the whole time,
that would be a trivial no-op.
But the trick was that after
we did the periodic extension,
we then took the series
of this and then passed
the limit onto the series.
So that's the trick.
So we think about generalizing
the aperiodic into periodic.
Then we take the series.
Then we pass the limit.
And we ask whether
the series converges.
And just like CT, the
answer for DT will converge.
So you start with
a periodic signal.
You write out the
DT Fourier series
just as we've been doing.
And you get an answer that
for this square pulse looks
very much like the
answer we got before.
The tricky thing
that I've done here
is I've written this series
on two axes, just like CT--
a k-axis, which is
the harmonic number,
and an omega-axis,
which is the frequency.
The frequency
represents the position
around the unit circle.
So capital omega is the
angle of the unit circle.
Then if I change the
period, the effect
of making the period bigger is
to put the harmonics closer.
But in a magical way,
because the envelope--
the thing showed by
the thin black line--
doesn't change as
I take the limit,
that's what enables me to think
about there being a limit.
As you make the period
bigger and bigger,
you get more and more
lines in an envelope
that doesn't change.
And then you can think
about the envelope
as being a function of the
continuous variable omega,
rather than the
discrete variable k.
And then you can
think about, what
would happen if
you pass the limit?
And the idea is that, if you
do the synthesis equation,
there's an ak that
depends on 1/n,
which you can write in terms of
the fundamental frequency omega
0.
And then as you pass
the limit, omega 0
is the spacing between
these harmonics.
So if you multiply
by the spacing,
you get the area of that block.
So the area associated with
N equals 0 is this area.
The area associated
with N equals
1 is that one, N equals
2, N equals 3, et cetera.
And so by doing the sum,
the sum increasingly
converges to the integral.
So you get precisely
the same kinds
of formulas we've
been using before.
The one thing that's
a little bit weird,
in the DT Fourier series, we had
a sum in the synthesis equation
as a sum in the
analysis equation.
Here, we get one of both.
The DT Fourier transform--
that's this thing--
is a function of the
continuous variable-- uh--
discrete-time Fourier transform
has a continuous frequency
variable capital omega.
Because it has a
continuous-- even though
it's a discrete-time
Fourier transform--
discrete-time Fourier transform
has a continuous frequency
variable cap omega.
So when we do the synthesis,
we have to integrate.
So one direction is a
sum, the other direction
it's an integral.
Other than that,
it's just the same.
So there's a striking parallel.
All of these things
are highly related.
The CT Fourier transforms
are highly related
to the CT Fourier
series, as is the CT
transform to the CT series.
And there's lots of connections.
And we'll talk about
that more next week--
how you can infer how one of
these transform relationships
would have worked from
all of the others.
For the time being,
the important thing
is just that, when you do
the DT Fourier transform,
you can think about that just
like the CT Fourier transform.
The CT Fourier transform was
evaluate the Laplace transform
on the j omega-axis.
Now, you evaluate the
z-transform on the unit circle.
The unit circle is no surprise.
That's what we've been doing.
Because of the relationship
between the DT Fourier
transform and the z-transform,
the DT Fourier transform
inherits all the nice
properties of the z-transform.
We'll make a bigger deal of
that in the upcoming two weeks.
In fact, that's the next
two weeks of this course,
is to figure out
the implications
of all of those properties.
But for today, what I
want to just close with
is one more example of how you
can think about these frequency
representations
helping you to imagine
the kinds of signal
processing that you
do or would like to do.
And so the last example now
is one from image processing,
instead of audio processing.
I started with audio processing.
Now, I want to think
about image processing.
Image has the property
that I'm going to have
to do something with 2D.
And in this class, we
primarily think about 1D.
But you saw in the zebra problem
that sometimes extending to 2D
is not hard.
And it certainly is the
case that the Fourier method
extending to 2D is
really easy, or at least
I'm going to say that.
So the way you can think
about a Fourier series
in two dimensions is
illustrated by this picture.
I took a picture
that 512 by 512.
That's the boat.
And I made a new picture
by taking this row,
calculating the Fourier
series for that row--
that had 512; so
it's 512 by 512.
So I took these 512 numbers,
took the Fourier series,
and wrote them here.
Then I took these 512 numbers
and put the Fourier series here
and repeat--
so fill the whole thing up.
So I took 512,
512-length sequences.
Then I took that
string of numbers,
took the Fourier series,
and put it there.
And then that one, take the
Fourier series, put it there.
Take that one, take
the Fourier series,
put it there, and build
up an image that way.
So I, row by row, took
all the Fourier series,
pasted them together.
Column by column, took
all the Fourier series,
pasted them together.
When you're done
with that, you get
what we call a two
dimensional Fourier series.
And what you see
on the right then--
so here's my original
picture 512 by 512.
Here's the picture of the
magnitude of the angle.
You can clearly see the boat.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's much clearer here.
So the phase looks
kind of random.
So to gain some insight
into what's in the magnitude
and what's in the
phase, what I can do
is generate a new picture by
setting the angle everywhere
to 0.
So I took the picture,
the magnitude,
and I did this to it.
I got the magnitude and angle.
I set the angles to 0.
And that's the picture I got.
So I was able to munge the
angle in the auditory thing,
and you could barely tell.
Can you tell that
I've munged the angle?
There's some distortion
caused by the angles.
There are some things
that you can still see.
So if you go back to this one,
there's these things here,
and there's these things
here, and there's--
And if you go to
this one, there's
some lines here,
and some lines--
Maybe there's something there.
But to a first order, it
kind of messed things up.
So then I did the opposite--
just throw away the
magnitude and substitute 1,
put 1 everywhere
there was a magnitude,
but put the angle back.
Now, you can almost
see the ship.
So throw away the
magnitude is better
than throw away the phase.
That's kind of cute.
Can somebody think of why
throw away the magnitude
might be better than
throw away the angle
when you're trying
to look at a picture?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Angle
determines resolution.
Magnitude determines
[INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN:
That's exactly right.
So if you muck around
with the phase,
you're changing the position.
Even in audio, when you
muck around with the phase,
you're changing when the
component comes out--
earlier or later.
In the picture, you're changing
when the brightness comes out--
earlier or later.
If you want to have
a nice straight line,
you better keep all
the phases lined up.
If you scramble them,
they end up scrambled,
and you don't see them anymore.
And as you said, the magnitude
is controlling the intensity.
So my intensities
are all screwed up,
but you can kind of
still see the lines.
You can almost even read--
if you know Polish--
you can almost read
what the title says.
So one more manipulation--
I took a different picture
and substituted the magnitude
of that different picture
in place of the magnitude
of the boat picture.
So angle with the boat,
magnitude of the mystery
picture, and it came
out pretty good.
But by the theory of
lectures, of course,
you know that the
way I did this was
to get a picture of
a different boat,
so that it would
be very similar.
And so that's what
the magnitude was.
[LAUGHTER]
So it doesn't
really matter much.
So I started with this
magnitude and angle,
substitute the mandrill's
magnitude, and you get that.
So it comes out pretty good.
So the idea then
is just that we've
looked at Fourier
representations
as an alternative
way of thinking
about the content of a signal.
And for many purposes,
like audio and video,
that alternative representation
is easy and insightful.
No class tomorrow.
It's Veterans Day.
Party next Wednesday.